hace casi medio siglo estos hombres
aterrorizaron a la población argentina
son responsables de algunos de los
crímenes más sangrientos de la dictadura
militar desde hace años están inmersos
en procesos judiciales y este miércoles
en buenos aires- el último juicio que
empezó en 2019 concluyó con duras
sentencias los cinco hechos de los 19
militares juzgados 10 fueron condenados
a cadena perpetua incluidos los ex
generales santiago riveros y eugenio
guañabens perelló fueron hallados
culpables de asesinatos torturas
violaciones desapariciones forzadas y
secuestro de menores
declarar que los hechos objetos de este
proceso son constitutivos de crímenes de
lesa humanidad en consecuencia los
delitos son imprescriptibles
entre algunas de las 350 víctimas que
siguieron el veredicto por
videoconferencia se encontraban madres a
las que les robaron sus hijos también
estaban ex trabajadores de la fábrica
mercedes benz que fueron secuestrados
cuando sus superiores denunciaron su
sindicalización
6 de estos trabajadores no volvieron a
aparecer tras su detención en el
complejo militar campo de mayo que
servía como un campo de concentración
del régimen organizaciones de derechos
humanos señalan que 30.000 personas
desaparecieron durante la dictadura
argentina desde 1976 hasta 1983 desde
que se levantó la ley de amnistía en
2006 los tribunales han dictado cientos
de sentencias por crímenes contra la
humanidad en un intento de reparar a
través de la justicia el violento pasado
de argentina